[Música]
el gobernador del estado estadounidense
de Florida ron de santis anunciará este
miércoles su aspiración a la candidatura
republicana así lo indicó la cadena Fox
que adelantó que la presentación será
hecha a través de Twitter en
conversación con elon musk Tenemos
reporte
el presidente de Bolivia Luis Arce le
pidió al Papa Francisco que comparta a
todos los archivos y expedientes sobre
abusos sexuales presuntamente cometidos
por sacerdotes esto tras conocerse la
investigación basada en el diario de un
fallecido jesuita español que detalla
los abusos que habrían sido cometidos
desde 1971
inicio en Panamá el juicio contra el
expresidente Ricardo martinelli y otros
Presuntos Implicados En el caso conocido
como New business el ex mandatario es
acusado de blanqueo de capitales para
comprar con fondos públicos una
editorial de medios por casi 44 millones
de dólares
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos crece la expectativa
luego de que las cadenas Fox news y mbc
news revelarán que el Gobernador
republicano de Florida Brown de santis
anunciaría su precandidatura
presidencial se espera que lo haga en la
tarde de este miércoles a través de una
conversación con el dueño de Twitter el
multimillonario elon musk previamente
Anthony belchico responsable de France
24 en Miami nos explicó el impacto que
podría tener este anuncio
Sí pues efectivamente rondes antes si se
anunciará finalmente como está previsto
este miércoles esa candidatura pues se
convertirían en el candidato más
conservador principalmente porque en las
últimas semanas ha estado aprobando
leyes muy controvertidas Como por
ejemplo la ley del aborto que reduce el
plazo para
abortar de 15 a 6 semanas también la ley
que permite el libreporte de armas en
Florida pero la más polémica ha sido la
ley
sb1718 que de alguna manera criminaliza
la migración irregular con penas de
hasta 15 años de prisión a quienes
transporten inmigrantes indocumentados a
Florida o también multas de hasta mil
dólares a las empresas que contraten a
indocumentados pero como les digo este
la candidatura de ron de santis se verá
verá esa pugna
Donald Trump pero también con otros
candidatos como Niki Halley la
exgobernadora de Carolina del Sur que
también se ha pronunciado sobre esta
posible candidatura de ron de santis
diciendo que él tiene la incapacidad de
interactuar con los votantes y también
hay otros candidatos que ya han
oficializado su candidatura por el
partido republicano de Cara a las
elecciones de 2024 Como por ejemplo Team
Scott que es el primer senador en negro
en más de un siglo en el senado de
Estados Unidos O también hasta hachinson
que fue dos veces gobernador de Arkansas
y ha sido uno de los pocos críticos uno
de los pocos candidatos que han sido
críticos con Donald Trump
la red social tiktok demandó al Estado
estadounidense de Montana por sus planes
de prohibir su uso en el territorio en
su demanda la compañía china califica la
prohibición como inconstitucional
alegando que vulnera el derecho a la
libertad de expresión la acción legal
llega una semana después de que el
Gobernador Estatal ratificara una ley
que prohibía a las tiendas de
aplicaciones ofrecer tiktok veamos el
informe sin perder tiempo tiktok
respondió a la prohibición Estatal de
Montana con una demanda la plataforma de
videos acusa al Estado de violar el
derecho a la libertad de expresión
garantizado por la Constitución
estadounidense
creemos que el proyecto de ley de
Montana aprobado recientemente Es
simplemente inconstitucional y como
usted ha señalado los presentados
recientemente una demanda para
impugnarlo ante los tribunales y
confiamos en que prevalecerá
la semana pasada el gobernador
republicano del Estado aprobó una ley
que ilegalizará que las tiendas de
aplicaciones ofrezcan tick tock a partir
del próximo enero en Montana ya está
prohibido en los dispositivos
gubernamentales y bloqueos similares
están en vigor en otros estados así como
en los dispositivos federales
Sí yo ya hay discusiones serias digamos
que Creo yo que más a nivel Estatal Hoy
hay discusiones serias a nivel Federal
de si se pudiese llegar a hacer esto
claramente aquí hay todo un complejo
sistema alrededor de lo que para los
norteamericanos es súper importante como
lo es la libertad de expresión y es
precisamente la razón por la cual tanto
la compañía Como algunos de los usuarios
de tiktok en Montana han demandado
a la al al Estado Estados Unidos teme
que la empresa matriz de tiktok la
tecnológica china bite Dance pueda pasar
datos de los usuarios al gobierno Chino
lo que supondría un riesgo para la
seguridad nacional Washington ha
presionado para que la empresa sea
vendida una compañía estadounidense O
podría enfrentarse a una prohibición
nacional lo que está en juego es el
destino de los generadores de contenido
y de al menos 150 millones de usuarios
de tiktok en el país
también en Estados Unidos fue publicado
un informe de la fiscalía del Estado de
Illinois que detalla que unos 2000
menores de edad fueron abusados
sexualmente por 451 integrantes de la
Iglesia Católica entre 1950 y 2010 el
texto de 696 páginas de talla que los
líderes católicos toleraron y ocultaron
casos las cifras mucho mayor a la de 103
personas que la Iglesia Católica había
señalado cuando inició la investigación
en 2018
es importante no ignorar la historia de
cómo se manejaron estos asuntos antes de
la investigación
y lo que eso requiere en términos de
transparencia y credibilidad en términos
de cualquier investigación futura
entonces para mí eso requeriría personas
creíbles fuera que la iglesia se
involucre en esas investigaciones
llegó a Bolivia Jordi bertomeu el
enviado del Papa Francisco para
investigar los casos de pederastia
presuntamente cometidos por curas
católicos y si bien la conferencia
episcopal boliviana aclaró que su visita
estaba pactada desde antes el religioso
llega cuando el país se enfrenta un
escándalo por la publicación de un
diario en el que un sacerdote reconoce
presuntamente haber abusado de 85
menores de edad el presidente Luis Arce
le pidió al Vaticano que investigue lo
ocurrido Ramiro cuevar berena no se
amplía
la conmoción continúa en Bolivia luego
de que se develará El Diario del difunto
sacerdote jesuita Alfonso pedrajas donde
confesaba haber abusado de por lo menos
84 menores durante su estadía en el país
dirigiendo escuelas para comunidades
marginadas al respecto la presidencia
boliviana informó que Se reserva el
derecho de admisión de nuevos religiosos
extranjeros y que envió una carta al
Vaticano con una petición al Papa
Francisco
que la justicia boliviana pueda acceder
a todos los archivos expedientes e
información referente a estas denuncias
y hechos de abuso sexuales cometidos por
sacerdotes y religiosos católicos en
territorio boliviano tras la difusión
del contenido del Diario de pedrajas la
justicia boliviana recibió al menos 8
denuncias por pederastia y algunas
víctimas se animan a querer contar su
caso
sólo pido justicia
porque nunca más se arrepientan
agresiones y hechos abominables contra
seres indefensos y estoy dispuesto y me
lo juego todo
algunos preguntan Y por qué ahora y por
qué yo respondo le digo sabes qué
preguntas lastiman
salen sobrando porque no sabes el
calvario que hemos vivido durante la
última semana Se realizaron
allanamientos en algunas escuelas
incluyendo el tradicional san Calixto y
la curia provincial en La Paz El
objetivo del gobierno boliviano está
definido esclarecer los hechos y
encontrar justicia para las víctimas
cancillería de Colombia le pidió al
gobierno de chile que Investiga los
responsables de la muerte del colombiano
Milton Rodríguez un hombre en situación
de discapacidad el pasado viernes en la
ciudad chilena de iquique cuatro
miembros de la armada del país austral
lo habrían golpeado varias veces incluso
con las muletas que usaba la cancillería
colombiana afirmó que Milton murió por
la gravedad de sus heridas y por eso le
pidió a Chile que se tomen acciones
legales Más allá de la suspensión de los
funcionarios la justicia colombiana
determinó mantener abierto un caso
contra el expresidente Álvaro Uribe por
presunto soborno a testigos y fraude
procesal según la jueza encargada Sí hay
pruebas de que el ex mandatario pudo
participar en la manipulación de
Testigos a través de uno de sus ex
abogados por lo que podría ir a juicio
en agosto pasado la fiscalía había
pedido el cierre del caso pero la
funcionaria determinó que no se
investigó lo suficiente abrívelo acusan
de supuestamente intentar comprar
testigos que lo señalaban de ser
promotor del paramilitarismo
en Ciudad de Panamá Este martes inició
el juicio por el caso New business
contra varios acusados entre ellos el
expresidente Ricardo martinelli quien
según la fiscalía habría blanqueado
capitales para comprar con fondos
públicos un conglomerado de medios esto
por alrededor de 44 millones de dólares
Martín el Lino estuvo presente en la
audiencia por una incapacidad médica
obviamente estaremos desahogando el día
de hoy un desahogo probatorio tenemos 37
personas testimoniales que van a ser
desarrolladas en el acto procesal y seis
periciales una vez culminado pues la
etapa de práctica de pruebas del
Ministerio Público procederá a
desarrollar su alegato de conclusión
donde pedirá lo correspondiente al
tribunal así llegamos al final de esta
informativo Les agradecemos su sintonía
[Música]